>> Mathematics is an intricate and fascinating language that we've developed to
understand and explain the world around us. Sometimes it can seem very
abstract, which can make it feel confusing or irrelevant. In this course we
will show you the relevance of this important branch of mathematics to your
everyday life.
>> Hi, I'm Julie Sliva Spitzer.
>> And I'm Miriam Swords Kalk.
>> And together with Sarah Norell, we'll be teaching college algebra.
>> In this course we'll approach algebra using real world scenarios.
>> We'll help a start up company handle its finances with its new product,
windshield wiper glasses.
>> We'll talk about hearing and sound, the age of the Dead Sea Scrolls, how panda
populations grow, and much more.
>> These stories will help you put the math in context.
>> To help you develop a deep understanding of mathematics, and learn how to
problem-solve more effectively.
>> So join us to learn how intuitive, relevant, and compelling algebra can be.